[Música]
en este momento es probable que esté
sentado para ver el video y permanecer
sentado unos minutos para verlo está
bien
pero Cuanto más tiempo esté en esa
posición más se perturbará su cuerpo
este cuenta los minutos hasta que se
levante de nuevo y lo lleve a dar un
paseo
puede que esto suene ridículo a nuestros
cuerpos les encanta sentarse verdad en
realidad no estar sentado por periodos
breves puede ayudar a recuperarnos del
estrés o recuperarnos del ejercicio
pero hoy nuestro estilo de vida nos hace
sentarnos más de lo que nos movemos y el
cuerpo Simplemente no está pensado para
una existencia tan sedentaria de hecho
es justo todo lo contrario el cuerpo
humano está diseñado para moverse y esto
se puede comprobar por cómo está
estructurado tenemos más de 360
articulaciones y unos 700 músculos
esqueléticos que nos permiten el
movimiento fácil y fluido
la estructura física única del cuerpo
nos posibilita ponernos de pie en contra
de la fuerza de la gravedad la sangre
depende de nuestro movimiento para
circular correctamente
nuestras células nerviosas se benefician
del movimiento y nuestra piel es
elástica así se amolda a nuestros
movimientos si cada centímetro del
cuerpo está preparado y a la espera de
que se mueva que sucede si no lo hace
empezaremos con el problema troncal
literalmente su columna vertebral es una
estructura compuesta de huesos y discos
de cartílago entre ellos
articulaciones músculos y ligamentos
Unidos a los huesos mantienen todo junto
una forma común de sentarse es con la
espalda curvada con los hombros caídos
una posición que presiona de forma
desigual la columna vertebral con el
tiempo esto desgasta los discos de la
columna vertebral sobrecarga algunos
ligamentos y articulaciones y presiona
los músculos que se estiran para
acomodar la posición curvada de la
espalda
esta forma encorvada también reduce la
cavidad torácica al estar sentados por
lo que sus pulmones tienen menos espacio
para expandirse al respirar
eso es un problema ya que limita
temporalmente la cantidad de oxígeno que
llena los pulmones y que filtra la
sangre
alrededor del esqueleto en músculos
nervios arterias y venas que forman las
capas de tejido blando del cuerpo el
acto mismo de sentarse aprieta presiona
y oprime Y estos tejidos más delicados
realmente se llevan la peor parte alguna
vez tuvo entumecimiento e hinchazón en
las extremidades sentado en las zonas
más comprimidas los nervios arterias y
venas pueden bloquearse y limitar las
señales nerviosas lo que provoca
sensación de adormecimiento reduce el
flujo de sangre en las extremidades y
las hincha
sentarse durante largos periodos también
hace desactivar la lipoproteína lipasa
una enzima especial de las paredes de
los capilares sanguíneos que descompone
las grasas en la sangre Así que cuando
se sienta no quema grasa tan bien como
moviéndose
Qué efecto tiene todo esto en el cerebro
la mayor parte del tiempo quizás se
siente para usar el cerebro pero
irónicamente largos periodos sentados en
realidad hacen lo contrario
estar sentado reduce el flujo sanguíneo
y la cantidad de oxígeno que entra en el
torrente sanguíneo a los pulmones el
cerebro necesita a ambos para permanecer
alerta por lo que sus niveles de
concentración bajarán conforme disminuya
su actividad cerebral
los efectos nocivos de estar sentado No
solo son a corto plazo
estudios recientes muestran que estar
sentado largos periodos está vinculado a
algunos tipos de Cáncer y a enfermedades
del corazón y puede contribuir a
problemas de diabetes riñón e hígado de
hecho los investigadores han calculado
que en todo el mundo la inactividad
provoca el 9% de las muertes prematuras
al año eso supone más de cinco millones
de personas así que lo que parece ser un
hábito muy inofensivo en realidad tiene
el poder de cambiar nuestra salud pero
por suerte la solución a esta amenaza es
sencilla e intuitiva cuando no tenga más
remedio que sentarse trate de cambiar la
postura desgarbada a una columna
vertebral recta y si no tiene que estar
atado al asiento intente moverse mucho
más tal vez con una alarma para
recordarle que debe levantarse cada
media hora pero más importante debe
entender que el cuerpo está creado para
el movimiento no para el sedentarismo
así que ya que el video está a punto de
terminar por qué no se levanta y se
estira debe a su cuerpo a dar un paseo
se lo agradecerá después
desea saber más sobre cómo funciona su
cuerpo mire este video sobre la relación
entre el sueño y la memoria o este video
sobre cómo los alimentos afectan su
cerebro
[Música]